well black friday typically kicks off
the holiday shopping season this year
the pandemic forced many retailers to
adjust their plans to avoid any large
crowds
eight news now reporter kate houston
spoke to some shoppers to see what they
thought of the changes
although the pandemic is changing how
people shop golden knights fans showed
out to city national arena
to safely score some black friday deals
instead of long lines and early crowds
many retailers saw a slower stream of
holiday shoppers this black friday
due to health and safety protocols
stores like the arsenal at city national
arena
only led a certain amount of shoppers in
at a time to keep everyone in the
holiday spirit
the arsenal brought in live music and
games for those that shopped in person
it's different but i couldn't just stay
inside it's tradition you've got to go
out and go shopping
it's way better i think the social
distancing part of it
so people aren't right behind you
instead of doorbuster deals many big box
stores promoted online deals and offered
curbside pickup some shoppers tell me
social distancing protocols
weren't necessary since there were so
few people inside
it's probably the weirdest black friday
shopping ever like
you know usually these lines are out the
doors around the corner today they
walked right in and didn't have to do
anything
due to the financial hardships of kovid
19 the nevada retail association
projects sales at brick and mortar
locations
will go down between 3 to 8 percent from
last year
however analysts expect online sales
will help fill in that gap
kate houston 8 news now